[Music]  Princess Charlotte is growing up and  looking more and more like her royal  relatives the Duke and Duchess of  Cambridge released new photos of their  daughter attending her first day of  school  on Monday and we feel like we're seeing  double  here's the side-by-side of Prince  William's two-year-old next to his late  mother Diana as a child from the light  hair to the wide-set eyes and sweet  smile the resemblance between the two is  almost uncanny I think it's pretty  impressive pregnant Kate Middleton  snapped the precious picks up the little  royal in red outside the Wilcox nursery  school in London while many are in awe  of Charlotte's likeness to Diana some  are saying she actually takes after her  great grandmother Queen Elizabeth the  second either way the genes in the  British royal family are strong  [Music]